Every dead character who stays dead in the
MCU is potential money that's slipping through
Disney's couch cushions.
So when a hero or villain takes a dirt nap,
you can rest assured there was a solid reason
for it, and possibly one that will have larger
implications down the road.
Many spoilers ahead!
Remember the Other?
In The Avengers, this double-thumbed alien
acted as middleman between Thanos and Loki.
In 2014's Guardians of the Galaxy, he's casually
murdered by an irritated Ronan the Accuser.
The madman wants Thanos's attention and is
frankly quite tired of the Titan's emissary
barking at him.
"I only ask that you take this matter seriously."
No, the Other isn't a major character, though
fans of early Joss Whedon TV shows Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and Angel were probably a little
disappointed to see him go.
The alien was played by Alexis Denisof, who
played Wesley Wyndham-Pryce, a Buffyverse
character initially so annoying it's amazing
no one ever broke his neck.
"Excuse me."
In the 2018 prose novel Thanos: The Titan
Consumed by Barry Lyga, we learn that Ronan
did more than dispatch an annoying intermediary
here.
The Other is a Chitauri, specifically the
only Chitauri to be a bona fide individual.
He negotiated Thanos taking over the leadership
of his people.
The rest of the Chitauri share a hive mind,
which is why they all die when their command
ship is destroyed in Avengers.
When Ronan kills The Other, it's really a
bit like finding the Holy Grail and tossing
it into an active volcano.
Of course, Ronan is also a psychotic maniac.
"He chose… poorly."
When Quicksilver was killed by Ultron in Avengers:
Age of Ultron, it was natural for many viewers
to assume the choice was made to forestall
any confusion between the MCU Quicksilver
played by Aaron Taylor-Johnson and the version
of the character introduced in Fox's X-Men:
Days of Future Past, played by Evan Peters.
"You didn't see that coming?"
Not according to Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige, who in 2015 told MTV that Quicksilver
died to elevate the stakes of Age of Ultron,
and more importantly to guide the future of
his sister Wanda, played by Elizabeth Olsen.
Feige told MTV the speedster's death acted
to
"...solidify Scarlet Witch's character, and
Wanda's arc in the movie and where we'll see
her in the next films."
If Quicksilver had lived, he maybe would've
had a thing or two to say about his sister
getting into a relationship with an android.
Whichever side Quicksilver would've chosen
in Captain America: Civil War would've likely
impacted Wanda's choices.
She may not have automatically sided with
him, but Quicksilver's support or lack thereof
could've affected her decision.
By the time Infinity War rolls around, it's
safe to assume that the Scarlet Witch we're
left with is one who is much more independent.
All the "decimated"
What exactly happened to the planet Xandar?
In Avengers: Infinity War, Thor explains to
the Guardians how Thanos and his forces got
the Power Stone:
"There are six stones out there.
Thanos already has the power stone because
he stole it last week when he decimated Xandar."
"Decimated" is a powerful word, but not a
specific one.
Did he literally kill everyone on the planet?
Or 10% of the planet for all you "that's not
what decimation means!" people.
You know who you are....
One tantalizing possibility: We're going to
see Xandar transformed in one of Marvel's
upcoming movies.
We may even see its Nova Corps grow closer
to the source material.
In Guardians of the Galaxy, the Nova Corps
is made up of relatively normal people..
In the comics, it's a different story: every
member of the Corps has super powers.
They're essentially Marvel's answer to the
Green Lantern Corps.
Instead of rings, they're given helmets that
grant them powers.
Their abilities aren't nearly as versatile
as the Lanterns', but at the same time they’re
a whole lot less CGI then them as well.
"Ahh Green!"
If Xandar survived after weathering two separate
assaults by alien maniacs, its inhabitants
may decide it's about time they build an army
capable of more than just piloting spaceships
and arresting raccoons.
They might do whatever it takes to found the
real Nova Corps.
Kurt Russell's Ego identifies as a Celestial
before his defeat at the end of Guardians
of the Galaxy Volume 2.
This race of mysterious beings has nearly
limitless power.
In the comics, they even hold the keys to
many of the universe's biggest mysteries.
That's one of many ways Ego differs from his
comic book counterpart, who is literally a
planet with a giant planet-sized face.
But that's not the part that's particularly
meaningful about his death.
Instead, it points towards one of the MCU
franchises we haven't seen yet.
We know Marvel Studios is gearing up to introduce
audiences to the Eternals, a race of superhumans
whose origins are very much intertwined with
the Celestials.
In the comics, the Celestials created the
Eternals specifically to defend the Earth
against their opposite the Deviants.
If the movie characters remains true to the
comics, it's likely we'll be learning way
more about the Celestials than we ever did
in Guardians of the Galaxy or any other Marvel
Studios films.
The fact that Ego was killed by an Earthman
could be of great interest to Marvel's newest
heroes.
"You shouldn’t have killed my mom and squished
my Walkman."
He evidently believed he was the only Celestial
in existence.
In Captain America: The Winter Soldier, we
learn that Arnim Zola died years before while
secretly working with the freshly resurrected
terrorist organization Hydra.
"Hail Hydra."
But Zola also sneakily transcribed his memories
and personality into data.
The result is an exposition scene outlining
what Hydra had been up to for 70 years.
It's also a clever visual tribute to the Arnim
Zola of the comics.
Curiously, there's something that's been left
completely unsaid in the MCU so far: For Hydra,
Arnim Zola Artificial Intelligence had to
have been an important step down a very specific
road.
In Avengers: Age of Ultron, we learn a piece
of vital information during a conversation
between Bruce Banner and Tony Stark about
the possibility of finally realizing their
Ultron project, Stark says his research on
the scepter leads him to believe Hydra was
using it to develop an advanced artificial
intelligence.
"Artificial intelligence."
"This could be it, Bruce.
This could be the key to creating Ultron."
If Stark is correct, then the creation of
the Zola A.I. must have been part of the research
that ultimately leads to the birth of Ultron
and Vision.
In fact, fans almost saw some persuasive evidence
to back up this theory.
In November 2016, some concept art from Ant-Man
leaked, and it revealed that director Peyton
Reed considered bringing Zola back for the
prologue scene at the SHIELD Triskelion, still
under construction.
Since Ant-Man was the first film to follow
Age of Ultron, it might have helped cement
the notion that Zola was, in fact, Ultron's
ancestor.
In Iron Man 2, Mickey Rourke's character Ivan
Vanko , also known as Whiplash, swears vengeance
on Tony Stark.
That's because Ivan was taught that Stark's
father Howard stole the idea for the game-changing
Arc Reactor from his father.
Twice in the film, we see a small bit of evidence
that seems to support this: design schematics
with Vanko's name listed before Stark's.
Nick Fury employs an interesting strategy
when trying to rein in Stark's crazy behavior:
He tells Stark that Vanko was full of it,
insisting that all of his claims of stolen
innovation could be chalked up to his anger
after being shipped off to Siberia.
"He spent the next 20 years in a vodka-fuelled
rage."
But we never definitively learn whether Whiplash's
father's accusations were valid.
Fury says they weren't.
In The Avengers, Fury also says that SHIELD
is only interested in the Tesseract because
of the clean energy it can provide, and that's
a big fat lie.
Fury is far from a reliable source.
It is curious that Vanko's name came first
on the schematics both on the copies Vanko
has early in the film and the one Stark finds
in the stuff S.H.I.E.L.D.
brings him from storage.
Regardless, we'll probably never get to the
bottom of this one.
Whiplash certainly didn't.
In Doctor Strange, the death of the Ancient
One raises questions that aren't answered
by the end of the film.
And even though Stephen Strange appears in
Thor: Ragnarok and Avengers: Infinity War,
those questions still have yet to be answered.
There are hints, perhaps, but nothing concrete
yet.
You know what we're getting at here.
Basically, what exactly happened to Kamar-Taj?
Immediately after the Ancient One's death,
Strange and Mordo head to Hong Kong.
By the end of the film, The Ancient One's
death leaves a huge void in Kamar-taj's leadership
and we have no idea who, if anyone, has stepped
up to fill it.
When you think about it, The Ancient One and
her students are apparently the only ones
standing between the MCU's Earth and hordes
of malevolent forces.
So honestly, the question of who's steering
the ship now that she's gone seems like a
pretty important one to answer straight away.
One of the hints we get is Doctor Strange's
conspicuous leap in terms of his mystic skills.
In Doctor Strange, he can barely keep up with
Kaecilius's henchmen.
But by Infinity War, the guy gives Thanos
a better one-on-one fight than just about
any other hero in the movie, and that's when
Thanos has four Infinity Stones.
Could it be possible that Strange was allowed
to assume leadership of Kamar-taj in spite
of being the new kid on the block?
"It's Strange."
"Maybe.
Who am I to judge?"
Discuss amongst yourselves.
Want to know our vote for the most surprising
death in 2018's Black Panther?
It had to be when Killmonger, played by Michael
B. Jordan, kills Ulysses Klaue.
"And to think I saw you as some crazy American."
Initially introduced as a weapons dealer in
the 2015 film Avengers: Age of Ultron, some
fans thought Klaue might be the main villain
of Black Panther, and for very good reason.
For quite a while, Ulysses Klaw has not only
been the Wakandan monarch's most persistent
foe, he was actually T'Challa's first enemy.
In the comics, Ulysses Klaue is much more
than a thief to Wakanda: He's the killer of
a king.
While trying to steal Wakanda's vibranium
for himself, it's Ulysses who murders T'Challa's
father T'Chaka.
Still just a boy, T'Challa shoots Ulysses
with his own sonic weapon, causing him to
be transformed into the villain Klaw, a being
composed of solidified sound.
Black Panther director Ryan Coogler didn't
like killing off Klaue.
In May 2018, he told the Toronto Sun:
"I like Klaw.
It really bugged me having to [kill him].
It's tough when you have to kill characters
off and I really did love that character."
"I'm sorry.
I'm so.
Ohhhh…
I'm sure that's gonna be okay.
I'm sorry.”
Considering Coogler's fondness for both Klaw
and actor Andy Serkis, could we one day see
Klaue return as a villain that's a little
closer to the source material?
It seems quite possible, especially considering
it looks like Coogler might be willing to
resurrect a certain special someone for Black
Panther 2.
"Just so I could kill you."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.